you got to get comfortable being
uncomfortable like what are some of the
weird things you do that you found
actually had a huge impact on your life
there he is well hello there how are you
evan
good how are you i'm great phenomenal
thank you very much
now are you on your your treadmill desk
i am on my treadmill desk if you want to
call it that it only goes like two miles
an hour so i can still type
at the same time you know i'm on a
trampoline
you're on trampoline i don't think the
way that i type
i don't think i'd be able to multitask
like that when i'm doing something like
this or typing i have to kind of put my
arm
on the desk just to just to control me
because otherwise i'm just i'd be
bouncing all day long
yeah that's a good thing like i really
love this treadmill desk they actually
don't make them anymore this company
in movements but i picked it up and i
just like to participate in some form of
low-level activity
during the day and you'll be surprised
when i'm in one of these conversations
or on a podcast or something i look down
and i i've done like three miles so it's
pretty cool
and what's it set to how fast it only
goes two miles an hour
okay only that's it that's the max speed
that is it so when i first got this i
thought that's not very fast is it going
to be any good but you know what it's
the perfect speed
for me to multitask and kind of work and
type at the same time it's got a big
desk so
i'm happy with it i love it well for
ladies and gentlemen if you don't know
chris he's a
legendary trainer uh health expert
biohacker
and i thought i'd bring him on to talk
about health for entrepreneurs because a
lot of business owners
entrepreneurs uh really struggle to keep
track of their health they're grinding
all day on their business
and i love i love even what you're doing
right now like somebody's working right
now they could be on the treadmill desk
working away still being productive and
also taking care of their fitness goals
yeah i think the major problem that a
lot of entrepreneurs have is that they
think
they have to go to the gym or do some
form of exercise for an hour
and if they don't have their hour they
don't do it so what i like to do with
a lot of my clients that you know than a
high level
you know or high stress businessman i'll
get them to do micro workouts so every
you know 30 minutes or so they go and do
like a minute of burpees and then
they'll do a minute of sit-ups and then
push-ups and sounded squats and jumping
jacks
and then by the end of the day you've
gone through quite a lot of calories and
it really does help with their blood
sugar regulation
so their blood sugar is that much more
stable so they're not getting as many
cravings they're not eating as bad
so i find that seems to be the perfect
entity for that there is an
actual bike called carol a.i artificial
intelligence as well
and basically it's like a five-minute
workout and that works
very well with a lot of entrepreneurs i
love it now you just finished coming
through
a fast are you done the fast are you
still on it i get i just broke it now
literally about 20 minutes ago yeah 36
hours
so fast and tears have taken off um i've
done a couple of them
my longest was early this month i did 66
hours
wow nice of just water
coffee in the morning uh but like black
uh and and sea salt like the pink sea
salt yeah um
and that's it for 60 for 66 hours i've
been doing fasting for quite a while now
for a couple of years
but you can see around 16 hours the
longest i'd gone was 20 hours
so last week i thought you know what
there's a lot of people out there during
this time of quarantine
that are kind of losing their discipline
at this time they're reading more
they're not exercising they're not
sticking to a schedule
you know even though they're at home
they're not getting up as early as they
should be you know so
you know i wanted a you know put in a
little bit more discipline into people's
lives
that can have a transcendence effect so
i thought you know what let's do
something that a lot of people don't
want to do that's fast
uh so we started like a little bit of a
facebook group start off with the 24
last week
36 this week next week it'll be uh 40
48 hour fast and uh
and then what i'm probably going to do
is continue with that group but then
maybe every day we'll be doing cold
showers
making sure that you're not hitting the
snooze button or something else you know
because
you got to get comfortable being
uncomfortable and and the group dynamic
i think is super important
to have other people who are doing it so
that you're not feeling like you're all
alone
you know what it's helped me for sure
because last night
you know i was hungry and i you know
during the day i'm fine because i'm so
busy
uh but during the evening when you've
got time to think and you're so you know
you know i'm not sleeping as good
because i'm hungry that's when it's
tough but having that group dynamic
and having that accountability you know
you're really putting your sincerity on
the line so i really like that it's very
powerful it's a
crowd source of inspiration what are you
telling people right now when they're
struggling to stay on their routine and
probably eating more than they should
and you know gaining that weight
because they're out of their regular
regimen yeah it all depends who i'm
talking to at the end of the day you
know it's like if you think of team
sports
which i never really enjoyed i've always
participated in individual sports
because
you can have a coach that just yells at
people and some of those team players
enjoy that they like that they're
receptive to it but other team players
need
some encouragement so i guess it all
depends who you're talking to at the end
of the day
but you know for the most part i'm just
telling people look we are going to go
back to normality
so do you want to be one step ahead
because it's going to be difficult for a
lot of people to get
back into the economic climate to get
jobs if they've lost their jobs or if
they're on part-time or whatever it may
be
they're going to have to be one step
ahead of the curve use this time for
introspective energy because
now we don't have to always be as
distracted
so you can actually listen to your
thoughts get a little bit more creative
don't have to have headphones in all the
time um so you can actually
you know figure out exactly what you
want to do and how you want to go about
it you know unfortunately like i've got
a gym franchise that i own in
india naval's been closed down uh for
the past
got eight nine weeks now and my
supplement sales for my supplement
company has been down a little bit
because we don't have the essentials
that people consider
such as vitamin c elderberry and stuff
like that we have more sports
performance
so i've had a side step and really work
on
my my books and my online training which
the bandwidth is expanded you know
immensely
which is great but i can only do that if
i continue to focus and wake up in the
morning
at the time that i usually do go to bed
at 8 30 like i usually do and stick to
that routine
of disciplinary action because funny you
said that a lot of entrepreneurs
don't have time to go to the gym i
wouldn't be an entrepreneur if i didn't
go to the gym because that gives me my
double a batteries in the morning
it provides the discipline that i need
to be structured
it provides the blood flow to my brain
so i'm more cognitive
receptive um so you know there's i
flunked in school i did tell
school i hated school but it wasn't
until i went to college to start
studying
uh health and sports therapy that i
started to retain that content
and it's because i've started exercising
feeding my brain and my body
with better fuel sources so whenever i
do uh some
talks at like universities i tell people
you know it's
great that you're studying it's awesome
that you are getting this education
but if you're not able to retain that
content because you're feeding
your brain and your body with the wrong
information
then you're not going to retain it so
you know that's part of the parcel
so let's talk about some of the weird
things that you do or at least normal
for you but other people might seem
weird so you've got
you're on the treadmill great i mean the
cold baths are now becoming a lot more
normalized i guess but the red light
therapy the
the coffee enema i don't even know what
that is
uh like what are some of the weird
things you do that you found actually
has
had a huge impact on your life uh yeah
for sure well you just named a couple of
them for sure
um well yeah people think it's a little
bit tin foil hat
you know i do like to ground myself
earth myself every day so i do have
earthing maps around the house but at my
desk as well
i sleep on an earthy maps but if i have
the opportunity to go outside it's been
raining all this week
i'll earn myself outside i find that's
really good especially
during the time now we have so much emf
and wi-fi
and x-rays and gamma rays around us i
think it's very important that we
get a lot of the negative eons from the
earth so that's one thing
i actually have a person called ryan
hoyer
from shielded healing coming to my house
this weekend
and he's a geobiologist and he will go
through the house to see
the highest levels of duty electricity
maybe in my bedroom so we have to make
sure that you know we can kind of
mitigate
that as much as possible so that's one
of the things the infrared light
therapy yeah sure i think it's
phenomenal really helps with
my circadian rhythm so i can sleep
better and obviously if i sleep better
especially my rem i'm going to be able
to retain more memory more
cognitive function so every morning i do
have
infrared panels shining on my balls and
everywhere else
and uh you know it's good for the skin
but obviously if i have the opportunity
to go outside in the sun
then i'm gonna get those restorative red
lights uh there as well
also with these blue light blocking
glasses for a couple of hours before
because you know must much of our time
is spent
on computer monitors on phone screens
tv artificial lights so again to release
that melatonin so i can sleep and relax
and not be stressed
uh you know it all helps with the
recovery because we always think about
go go go
burning a candle at both lens you know
let's see how hard we can work and how
long we can work
but you can only do that if you optimize
your recovery
so recovery is always at the forefront
of my brain
so i can perform and be a little bit
more efficient with uh what i put out
we see what else i have pemf yeah you
mentioned the coffee enemas
only do that once a week i don't make
that a daily habit
and uh you know is that a pill like i
don't even know what
i don't know if i want to ask do i want
it no no no no no
it's uh it it goes it goes uh in a
different orifice not the mouse
so yeah much like you know uh colonic
hydrotherapy if you will
um you know you just do this from home
and you want to make sure that you get
in there
you wouldn't want to be putting folgers
up your butt you want to make sure that
you have a high
grade coffee that is organic that is
mido toxin-free because unfortunately in
the u.s
we have higher levels of mitotoxins in
our grains in our coffee
in our wines so uh if you're mold
sensitive
then that's definitely going to have a
negative impact
but is it like coffee like a pill coffee
that you put it is it the liquid
like harry yeah so you grind it put it
in a french press
fill up that french press then you put
it in a proper enema
kit okay and then you can lie on the
floor in your bathroom or wherever you
want
and then you just slowly allow this
coffee
you know because obviously the container
has to be higher than you
for gravity to take it up right yeah so
it's a
reptile uh you take this coffee and then
you just hold it there for about 15
minutes and then you go to the toilet
and
you feel clean as a whistle after and
and
so why coffee instead of just water or
something else i'm just here like what's
the benefit you're seeing
yeah you you get like a lot of selenium
you're going to get a lot of polyphenols
that you're not going to get out of
water and you know
there's very few studies that do show
this
uh but i've noticed that my liver
enzymes do decrease
the inflammatory responders in my liver
uh do decrease from doing coffee enemas
and you know i learned this from
my friend ben greenfield so i just been
following that protocol and it worked
for me so
it works for me i'm going to do it it's
not something that i tell people to do
right you've got to figure these things
out yourself it's the uh like how deep
in the christmas world do you go
right like the starting point is the
diet and the working out and maybe ice
baths and then we start going
going more i mean i love that stuff i
think i think people write it off
as tin foil hat but just why don't you
just try it for
a week and just see if it works for you
yeah for sure the fundamentals have to
be in place unfortunately in the
biohacking world
people who have money see these shiny
objects and get everything and think
they're going to live to
pass 100 years old but without the
fundamentals of your sleep
your hydration good food you know
organic humane raised wild caught etc
um and you know really focusing on those
stress levels of stress hormones so
waking up in the morning make sure that
you're not reacting to your phone
maybe you start the day with meditation
mindfulness and
manifestation you know all these things
are going to have
an impact that are free and then you can
look at the shiny objects of
you know and then you can start
quantifying so i wear an aura ring
which tells me what my deep sleep cycle
is what my rem is so you can see
actually
what is working and what isn't i do wear
a 24-hour blood glucose monitor as well
i'm not diabetic
but that tells me you know what sort of
implications
certain foods or environments have on my
blood sugar variability
so if i have an ice bath in the morning
my blood sugar levels are much more
stable
and i've noticed as well because it
tones your vagus nerve
you're much more emotionally stable as
well so you
you're able to react to certain
situations especially if you're an
entrepreneur
much better with more cloudy than you
would otherwise
so it's constantly measuring your blood
your blood sugar level
24 7. yeah so you've got an app on the
form there's two
that i wear um there's one called the
nacho libra
and the other one is called a dexcom six
the sex plum six
is a little bit better you know a
thinner needle uh so it's not as
uh uncomfortable and i'll stay there for
about five six days wow
that's wild so it's just always in you
always yeah you see your third like in
the backyard you can put it in your
waist i don't wear it
on the waist because i wear weights belt
when i go to the gym you know and it can
be uncomfortable if i'm going running
or anything like that so back the arm
seems to be pretty good it's
specifically for diabetics
you know so you don't have to keep
pricking their finger because i type so
much
i don't want to be pricking my finger
every day makes sense
so for the sleep ring i'm always curious
what
what changes have you made so great so
you know that you
you didn't get enough rem sleep last
night how do you then
use that and and make a practical change
to your life so that you fix the sleep
result
so i always look to see what i did the
night before that may have impacted it
so this is how i kind of got into
biohacking initially because i went to
uh
doctors for now clinic in oldsmar
florida for six weeks
because i had mold toxicity from when i
was living in
mumbai india which led to me only having
like about three hours sleep at night it
was horrendous
but but i had that typical
entrepreneur's spirit where
i don't care i'm still gonna run my
businesses i'm gonna outwork everybody
i'm gonna out train everybody
go go go and uh you know i wasn't a good
person to be around so
you know i expended all of my
uh options when it came to natural
therapies natural supplementation
even some types of medication and when i
went to dr spenard's clinic i found out
about this
mold toxicity and following that the six
weeks there the
severe detoxification protocol i really
started quantifying everything
and sleep was obviously one of the major
things so i've worn the roof
i've worn the biostrap the aura i find
it really really good for sleep
and the changes that i make come from
supplementation like magnesium is
something that we are all pretty much
deficient in today
so making sure that i have plenty of
magnesium in the diet or supplement with
it you can even bath in it
which magnesium are you using uh there's
a company
called calm that's a magnesium but the
one
that i use is by a company called by
optimizers
and they have a magnesium that i think
is very efficacious
but also bathe in magnesium flakes as
well you know
and um and if i go so there's a place
here
called still water float and they do
float therapy and i don't i don't think
float therapy tanks yeah is it is it in
in total darkness
too because yeah yeah okay that's it so
sensory deprivation so
occasionally i'll go there and it's like
1200 pounds of magnesium
that you're floating in so you get a
good night's sleep after that you know
but there's certain types of cbd that
i'll take you know
but at a very high dose like 100
milligrams
uh to help with the deep sleep cycle as
well and
uh tryptophan i have found is being the
number one
the number one supplement at about one
to two grams to really help with their
sleep
and obviously further from the
supplementation having a weighted
blanket
making sure the room is completely dark
if not you're wearing an eye mask
um yeah the bed has to be of high
quality obviously because we spent you
know nearly half of our time in it
they said you got a book coming up i
know you've done some others in the past
so what what's the new book all about
well the book is just released uh this
one's just released it's called man of
iron so um it's all on like hybrid
athleticism because a lot of people that
are into bodybuilding they don't think
that you should do any endurance
and a lot of endurance athletes believe
that you shouldn't do any strength
training
so i kind of merged both of them
together because i've always done cardio
every day twice a day
even as a bodybuilder and a bigger
person and a lot of people
including my peers told me that it
shouldn't be done you should be a static
ornament and just contain all these
calories that you're eating
however i felt that you know the most
important muscle that we have is not
just our pecs or our doubts it's our
heart
um so i've always worked uh my heart and
uh
so i decided to prove a lot of people
wrong by saying okay i'm going to give
myself six months to do something
extreme what's extreme an
iron man triathlon so uh i went to the
lab did all the tests to show that i
wouldn't lose any muscle
i increased my ftp my lactate threshold
and actually put on
uh just under a pound of muscle during
that six months but i've continued to do
iron man and
ultra marathon and spartan but still
train like a bodybuilder as well
and so a lot of people have actually got
into hybrid athleticism now
and the book is all about how to do both
but
remain injury-free because funnily
enough
more people get injured like runners for
instance as opposed to strength trained
athletes or bodybuilders or power
lifters
so uh that's something that i wanted to
put out there to show that you can
do both because so many people said yeah
i took up kind of strength training
but i had to give up running or a lot of
people started running and
vice versa so uh you know you don't have
to give up both and i love actually
doing both
i'm not going to excel in each one of
them but we can participate
for injury prevention is it is it the
stretching is it
just the frequency is it the muscle
building like how do i
how do people again it comes down to
recovery optimizing recovery so sleep
uh making sure that you're getting all
the right nutrients into your system
you know so if i'm going out on a bike
ride and i'm going for like 100 miles
i'm not taking a couple of gels with me
i've got a little backpack
and i actually have my supplements i
have food in there as well so
it's kind of like a traveling buffet if
you will uh but
you know for instance when a very few of
us are going to get injured on a bike or
swimming it's usually running
so i usually recommend that people if
they have the opportunity to either run
on a curved treadmill or on the trails
as much as possible only do the solid
work when you're doing more
um you know race specific uh towards the
end of your of that cycle and do a lot
of ankle rotations
and a lot of mobility work with the
metatarsals in your feet because
the metatarsals in your feet are your
suspension but because we wear trainers
the majority of the time
our feet switch off and we need to turn
them back on and improve the flexibility
within those bones so
i suggest people wake up in the morning
and start rolling to begin with like on
a tennis ball
and then they can move up to a golf ball
and usually when people
stand on a tennis ball for the first
time it's extremely painful
because that connective tissue in the
foot has just become so
tight but if you think about it and you
see people who are barefoot runners
especially trail runners their hat their
feet are more like claws they're more
like hands
and that's how we're supposed to be huh
so are you running in the in the vibram
shoes at the barefoot shoes
i have the uh the vibo barefoot on me
right now
okay now we're gonna see it this is it
yeah oh what are those oh are those the
ones that are those the japanese ones
that wrap
i know the the vibo barefoot these are
fibo barefoot oh bible okay okay okay
yeah but i do have the vibrams as well i
actually have the vibrams
so here's a nice little hack for you
with something called an
earthy stratum so it's like a a bar
like a sticky bar that that bends that
goes from the inside your foot
to the outside of your soul so for
instance if you're flying like you know
i know that you travel a lot
very little opportunity usually for you
to earth yourself especially if you've
been
up and on the plane surrounded by the
gamma rays and people on wi-fi
people on phone and then you have to go
straight to your hotel
and then you go straight to into your
taxi or whatever it may be
you don't earth yourself because you're
wearing rubber souls
so these bars my fiance just brought
this to me now
they actually stick from the inside your
foot
and connect with your foot to the
outside
just like that so i usually wear these
with my vibrams or my
my vibe oh barefoot so there's a little
biohack for you
wow you're actually going out and
putting your feet
on the grass especially if you're
traveling and you're working you know
what it's like
you don't even see daylight so that
really helps and another little biohack
if you're not seeing daylight because
you're just seeing hotels and conference
rooms
there's uh a handheld infrared device
called the jew go
and you'll just i don't have it in here
i've just got the box
but then you can actually shine the
restorative red light on your face
into your retina in the morning at night
so when you do go into that new time
zone you're able to get into it that
much more because you're telling your
brain
okay it's sunrise it's dusk i love it i
love it this is this is all great
i got i got lots of notes so i gotta
start i gotta start researching and
working on
now quickly tell me about youtube i mean
that's where most my audience is that's
what people are gonna you know watch
this video
as well you've got so much knowledge
you're still learning you're still
applying are you are you bringing it to
youtube is it a platform you care about
what are you what are you up to there
yeah i definitely need to do more on it
there's more there's definitely more
that i need to do
you know i was kind of old school and i
started on uh facebook
and i i was even really pushed to start
facebook so i was like fan page why do i
want a fan page
but i got over a million followers there
but i never really put the time and
effort that was
needed into youtube because i do
understand
if i'm to provide education then youtube
is going to be the best platform in
order to do that
so i'm actually start kind of starting
that process a little bit more seriously
now
and there seems to be a lot that i don't
know in regards you've got to have a
certain
thumbnail the tags the text has to be
correct
uh something that's attractive so i want
to try to cross off all those p's and
queues
before i dive into it you know up until
now i've more so dab my toes so i might
be coming to you for some advice there
i'm happy too man cross off the piece
i've never even heard of that
how are you crossing out for p or q the
p and the q's
maybe it's a british term yeah i ge i'll
probably but like where does it how does
it what are you crossing
you just cross out the t's that's that's
what we would say oh
right cause you cross off a team i think
it's like a cockney term
p's and q's all right yeah i mean the
youtube's great because the content
lives forever because whatever you make
whatever you post on instagram nobody
cares in three days
in two days exactly but youtube the
videos from
five years ago could still be getting
you views and attention and traffic and
interest
and interesting speaking with you in the
depth of knowledge
that you have there's so many things i'm
sure whatever question like you have an
answer
with decades of experience on would be a
great
format for you even just sharing your
thoughts without making it look
super fancy in the in the editing
because the quality content is more just
what's in your brain in your head and
your experience yeah exactly and from
what i understand it seems to be
expanding on that platform as well now
obviously you've got the youtube live
and like there's youtube is there
youtube stories
that i've been told as well yeah youtube
story so i really need to take a deep
dive into this platform
you know when it comes to a lot of the
advancements when it comes to technology
i'm not very good
i need someone to tell me so then i'm
directed to do it
and youtube you know like you know if
you're going to google search something
the chances of it coming up with an
instagram post is going to be very
little
youtube is going to be very high
instagram is
it's fast it's candy it's caffeine right
um
youtube because you're trying to build
something like you're building a legacy
here you've been doing this
for so long but but you're also not done
anytime soon
no i feel like i just got started yeah
for sure the message like if you said
hey i want to i want to pump and dump
this thing i just want to build my
fitness brand up for the next three
months and then move on to something
else then
forget youtube but because like this is
a legacy play like your
your grandkids will be watching the
videos that you make
yeah i'll have to be careful with my
language
[Laughter]
it's been pretty good um yeah i think i
think you would crush it i think you
would crush it not just
not just from the the you know lifting
weights and training side but the mental
side the
the the science side i think that you
bring it down in a way that makes it
easy to understand and
entice this kind of curiosity that it's
not tin foil hot
like i want to try this stuff out so
yeah and has that always been your focus
this is going to be my primary platform
in order to get my message out
is that like where you've always come
from or did you start more so on
facebook or
instagram you know where did you direct
a lot of your information to from the
very beginning
i started on on my website so that was
and then
google and seo people searching and
finding stuff then i moved heavily to
linkedin and facebook but um i've i fell
in love with youtube because one it's a
visual i'm a visual guy i might rather
see something
yeah me too i must rather see something
if this was an audio interview
i'd be here with my eyes closed just
like really trying to listen because
auditory is the worst for me
so be able to see you uh helps and so
making videos
especially long form um youtube is a is
a natural place but the thing that
really stole me on it is that
the videos you make in a year five years
are still getting views and they don't
just disappear yeah yeah exactly
and you know one thing that i've been
messing my you know this will probably
be another conversation offline
but i've got a huge i've got a knowledge
and mileage podcast is called
and uh you know i've been playing toy
with the idea okay if i'm gonna start
going heavily into youtube
do i have a separate channel for the
podcast because maybe not everybody
wants to watch the podcast
a couple of talking heads maybe people
aren't searching
me for that particular content of
whoever i'm interviewing or whatever
so maybe i should have a completely
separate channel or put it all into that
but
you know that's a another and that's
another conversation again yeah really
just thinking audience like if there's
enough of an overlap
then i would say keep it on the same
channel especially if you're not
producing enough content
for the main channel um and then just
see like if all your fitness stuff does
well the podcast just always tanks every
time then maybe move to a different
channel
but typically if it's a similar audience
you keep on the same channel
if you said i want to make a new channel
where i'm going to be speaking
russian great like that's a different
channel yeah you don't put it it's just
different languages different audience
different channels
yeah yeah exactly i'm gonna say because
like i have like i said i've got a gym
franchise in india
and there's a lot of people that i know
that are high
high level influencers but whenever they
put out content
in the english language it doesn't do
that well
but when they put it in their native
like hindi language
millions millions so they've all
converted to that particular culture
uh to feed the content because in india
obviously you've got so many people not
only just in the country around the
world
that still talk the native language yeah
well it's crazy how fast time flies it
was awesome to have this conversation
you gave me a whole bunch of homework i
need to get in on
um anytime you want to talk youtube i'm
happy to help i mean
been on for 11 years we've got two
million subscribers plus and
love phenomenal i checked it out very
very impressive
you know congratulations that's off to
you
i love to see you blow up there too i
think your message is is just as
important and can change the lives of so
many people
um and for people who are watching this
live or on youtube they want to dive
deeper into
your world what's or buy the book like
what's the next step you want them to
take
it's probably best if they just come to
my instagram to be honest with you chris
k r i s getting g e t h
i n and they can find everything that
i'm about there but maybe next time we
have a conversation i'll be directing
people to my youtube
there we go i love it thank you chris
appreciate all the wisdom and time and
everything you're doing
hey thank you very much it's been a
pleasure thank you sir
awesome thank you man if you want to see
the one on one i did with ed my let
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there